look up.
>> I don't know. I wasn't listening.
>> If we had, let's say theoretically, if
people had seen everything that you guys
are typing in these servers, the only
time you ever use a tool that could look
up somebody's real life identifying
[music] information, this is the only
time it's ever happened.
>> Are you talking in [music] like my time
online or what? What are you talking
about?
>> Do I do you want me to repeat the
question?
>> So, you're saying like in that server?
>> Thank you for the five gifted. Huge
appreciate. Thank you so much. goes on
in that server.
>> Okay.
>> But I mean, most of the most of the time
it's just
>> You have no idea then. Okay. If you were
to find out that that kind of stuff was
going on in that server,
>> would that be upsetting to you?
>> Well, personally, since you guys lie and
redact everything to smear people, I
probably would have to look at it. But
>> anyway, I'm sure you guys don't
understand that I asked at all. You
know, that wasn't a question I saw,
right?
>> Whatever. This whole you redacted a
giant creator's name.
>> We're not Don't worry about the redacted
thing. Okay. So, if you found out that
these types of tools were used in the
service that you were in, that would
upset you, right? Because you don't know
about it, right?
>> It depends on what they're using the
tools for and if they're publicizing
private information. If they're
publicizing private information, then
yeah, that's doxing.
>> If you're a researcher though and you
make videos, there's lots of things that
you use, but what matters is if you
publish it. If you're using it to harass
somebody that Yeah. So,
>> let's say you chop celery or stuff.
>> Go get some more tea. Okay. Let's say
that you were to have unmasked that
account that you said was harassing
Pinky Chew or whatever.
>> What would you have done with that
information?
>> I was going to give it to the person who
had a protection order because they were
being harassed and stalked.
>> Mhm. And that protection order protected
them from all bad words on the internet.
Is that what you're saying?
>> Uh they aren't supposed to harass You
aren't He's If a mod of his, right, if
they're like coordinating harassment
against her or someone close to him,
then yeah, that's bad. Then I'm sure she
would want to I'm sure I'm sure that she
would want to know about that to
>> to tell.
>> The idea is that they might be techone
or someone directly connected and
therefore the protective order would
apply it like you were before. It's
okay. You can keep daming him. Okay.
>> How about you have the conversation
discussed?
>> I'm going to have I'm going to have
Okay, I'm going to ask the same question
again. Okay. Listen really carefully. I
know you like to ramble on some random.
>> If you would have unmasked the account,
if you would have figured out the real
life identity,
>> you just asked this question. I told you
I would take it. Your brain is like,
>> "Hey, you low life." Listen to the
answer, you disgusting low life pervert.
>> Let me let me Okay, let me ask it again.
You're having a lot of trouble with
this. Okay. If you would have unmasked
the account and figured out the real
life name of that account, would you
have passed that information on to
Pikachu?
>> No.
Why? It had nothing to do with that. It
was about us just being like, "Oh, is
this a mod or not?" It had nothing to do
with like getting someone's real name.
>> How would you have known? Do you know
the names of all of Techton's mods?
>> No, [laughter]
I No. Oh, you mean
>> you could cross reference that with the
chats and see if they've got
>> reference it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, let me ask again. You're not
understanding me.
>> If you actually understand you, I've
answered you twice now.
>> You figure out who the person is, their
real life name.
>> No, you're See, you are inserting that.
That was not that was not the point of
any of that. That wasn't what anyone was
trying to do. But you want to push that
>> because you're trying to push this crazy
[__] narrative that all these people
are
>> trying to ruin you and everything when
the reality is is that
>> you shared unconsensually revenge porn.
You were sexing Rose when she was
underage and she was sending you [__]
and all that other stuff, but you want
to try to use this.
>> Actually, it was a man pivoting. Keep
pivoting.
>> Did you say yep to revenge pool Destiny?
Say yep. You did share revenge porn. Is
that why she destiny? Say yep. Pivot.
Very very very simple.
>> That would that would look good in court
documents. That would look awesome in
court.
>> We've had where you've actually been
brave enough to be mean to me by the
way.
>> I brought careful was up to you. Keep
lying about this but keep going. Keep
going loser. Keep going. You [__]
worthless low life dude.
>> So Shamu I'm going to ask very very
simple. Very simple. You gota coaching
you. You can do this. Very very very
simple. Quere you the one that DM'd that
it was just a lull archiver to uh
>> Yep.
>> Ah I misunderstood.
>> Interesting. You misunderstood even
though you had no Were you part of that
room? Did you click that?
>> I was not in that I was not in that
conversation. I just looked up
afterwards trying to check if that's
kind of interesting. So you were
messaging Chud. You were in his DMs
trying to twist a narrative about facts
that you didn't possess? That's kind of
crazy cuz didn't Chad just accuse me of
doing that but couldn't give a single?
>> I thought I thought I had the facts. I
was wrong. I thought I had the facts.
Shimu Shimu. Very very simple question.
>> We've admitted it's a mistake.
>> Yeah. Everyone said it's mistake.
If this tool would have been used no
super simple question. If this tool
would have been used to unmask the real
life name of this person, would you have
passed that along to Pig?
>> You have you already asked that?
[laughter]
What is wrong with your brain? You
literally have already asked this
question. I told you no. I was only
interested to see if it's a mod or not.
>> And my question was, how would you know
if it's a mod if you don't know the real
life names of all of Techton's mods? How
would you know that?
>> You literally already This doesn't
matter.
>> Why would you not send it to Pinky?
defend sending it to Pinky Chu. Why
wouldn't you send it to Pinky Chu? If
she's got a protective order against
Teone and Teone or someone close to him
is harassing her, yes, pass that to
Pikachu. Who gives a [__]
>> Okay, that's cool. So, you're willing to
unmask accounts that you perceive as
harassing Pikachu online?
>> I like how you're trying to use unmask
and play doxing when doxing is
specifically the publication. We're
talking about privately sending it to a
relevant party.
>> So, okay, that's fine, too. So then just
to be clear, if I were to figure out the
real life identity of somebody and I
just sent that to somebody else, you
wouldn't consider that doxing.
>> It's that's not technically doxing
though. That's not for a legitimate
purp. Let me ask again. Let me ask
again. If somebody were to unmask an
account on Twitter, they figured out who
the real life identity was and they sent
that personally identifiable information
to a friend or somebody else. You
wouldn't consider that doxing?
>> No, I would consider that sending
someone's docs information, but not
doxing.
>> What about in a public Discord? You
would
>> if it was if they sent the information a
public discord that would be doxing.
>> The publication is what I see as the as
a key element of doxing.
>> I don't know if we would count this one.
>> I don't know if you count this Discord
as public or private cuz it
>> I count as a public discord. That's a
100 person Discord. That's a public
disc.
>> 100 people in that [__]
>> So, all right.
>> So, you don't really have any
>> I thought I thought we were cool. Damn.
What the [__] bro? [laughter]
>> I mean, you're you're honestly I'm gonna
be for real. Shimu, you're Yeah, I gotta
be honest, man. You're [__] caught up
in [__] and I'm I feel bad, bro. I do.
>> Oh, [__] off, Dan. You're such a So, you
guys got nothing else in the world. You
guys have nothing else to Is that it?
>> Is this what you've got? You've got a
link to see what what's happening right
now.
>> You've got a link to a tool that was
used to look up Twitter usernames. I
just want you guys to condemn here.
>> I want you to defend it as hard as you
can.
>> I I will defend sending that to Pikachu.
You should send that to Pikachu if you
think it's a moderate data.
>> Wait, wait. [music] I didn't know that.
Wait, is that true? This is just a tool
that allows you to look up Twitter
usernames.
>> No, I didn't say that, did I? I said it
was what it was used for. I didn't say
the tool is only for that. [__]
listen, you little wretch.
>> That's also not my bad. My bad. My bad.
My bad. Okay, I didn't hear you. Okay,
so you you know the search that they ran
on this tool.
>> Well, I don't know the search. I've been
sent a screenshot and obviously I can't
verify it because I don't know, you
know, I can't verify the screenshot. I'm
going off.
>> Hold on, Chud. So, somebody sent you
another fact to
>> Nandra sent it for me. Yes. have the
information about
>> was Nandro just sent it to me. So, okay,
if you just listen.
>> Who's filibustering now? You [__]
pedo. Who's [__] filibustering now,
dude?
>> Keep going. Yeah, go ahead.
>> No, dude. You are filibustering. You
complain about me earlier. Now you're
doing it.
>> Yep.
>> Nandra sent it to me.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Nandros.
>> Oh my god. Nandros sent it to me. Okay.
So, I can't verify whether Nandros is
telling the truth. I am definitely
relying on some trust in the Canandross
having known him for a little while. He
could be lying to me, right? But I
believe I don't believe I
>> based on the screenshot saying like the
username and the fact he a screenshot
looking at us. I think it was just used
by a third party to check previous
usernames on Twitter. I don't classify
that as doxing. Do I think it's like the
best online behavior? No, probably not.
I think using tools that Kiwi Farms use
isn't necessarily the best online
behavior, but I don't think it's quite
the same as posting someone's name in
[__] you know, chat like you [__]
did. So, the point is to the smaller
crime, right? We say, "Well, I don't
think it's okay." Right?
>> Oh, [__] off, dude. The smaller crime.
That's not what I'm doing at all.
>> I'm just trying to figure out what I'm
saying to you. No, I'm saying to you,
dude,
>> you're going to repeat the same [__] you
just said. I don't know why you're going
to pay it, but go ahead. Well, I know
why it's cuz you're nervous. Go ahead.
>> Okay. What I'm saying is that I could
have an issue with using the tool, but
in this case, it doesn't really seem to
be of use for anything beyond checking
the username.
>> I understand you. Yeah, you've just said
>> and that's what Nand just said to me,
and I believe Nandra cuz I trust him.
That's where I am with this. So, what is
your response to that? What is your
response to that?
>> My response is one,
>> I thought Nandra said he didn't run the
search. Did I misunderstand that?
>> No. Nandros said a third party ran the
search. He asked a third party to look
up previous Twitter usernames
>> and the third party was using a tool
that he posted in the Discord but he
didn't use
>> he didn't post it mentioned it post he
mentioned it
>> he mentioned it he mentioned it and he
says I'll throw it across to a third
party so this is backed up by the
message exchange
>> okay so then the third party only
searched for Twitter usernames
>> well I don't know what the third party
did and didn't do right I can't No,
didn't you say earlier?
>> No, I didn't. No, I didn't say that.
>> Initially, I thought you said it was
used just to look up Twitter users and
then I clarif.
>> True. That's fine. Okay, that's great.
That's a good Okay, so it was a full
docs that they were running on this
account. They didn't find anything, I
guess, right? So, nothing was published.
>> What do you mean it was a full doc they
were running on this account? A doc is
when you publish it, you lying pervert.
>> No, you said doxing is when you publish
something. You said if you send a doc to
somebody that You send doc information.
Docable information.
>> Oh, doc. Doc. Was that the
>> doable? Doable. A B L E.
>> I got to write down all these. Sorry.
What is What does doxible mean? What
does that mean again? Is that like a
username? Is docable or
>> as in something that information you
could use to do someone, you [__] What
do you think? What do you think I'm
saying?
>> Username? I don't know what you're
saying. I've never heard the term
docable in my entire life.
>> As in information that if you published
it, it would be doc. It would be doxing.
So it would just be docs not doxable.
>> No, the docs is when you publish it.
It's doxable information. If you used
it, it would be doxing.
>> So like is a username docable or
>> um it depends on the username. If it's
their public facing main username, then
no. If it's a username that leads back
to say it's like you know your
username's Stevie B, that could be
doxable.
>> Okay.
>> Oh my god, dude. This Ridiculous.
>> Did a full doc look up on this account.
That's what
>> Who's you guys? Who's you guys? Who's
you guys?
>> Who did it?
>> Whoever was on this Whoever's on the
server.
>> No, no one on the server did the search.
>> They were posting a tool in here and
they were the ones.
>> They mentioned a tool. They mentioned a
tool and said a third party would search
it.
>> Who's the third party?
>> One of Himpleton's friends apparently.
That's what logs say.
>> I wasn't in the conversation, so I'd
actually Yeah.
>> True. And listen, you know what? Maybe
that's fair. So then my question is, is
it an ordinary practice that for this
particular server, you don't actually do
the lookups in the server, but you
always request it from a third party? Is
that ordinary?
>> I I don't I don't do lookups in the
server, so I've got no [__] idea.
Ordinary question. Sorry, hold on. I
have a question.
>> Wait, wait, no, wait. I'm I'm just
trying to understand. You said they
didn't look it up in this server. That's
that's really good. So there's no doxing
happening on that server, but you said
they passed it off to a third party. I'm
asking, do you know who the third party
is, and is it ordinary? No, I'm purely
I'm purely going off of the law. I'm
going off of the evidence. Nicandross
says in the logs he's giving it to a
third party. And then says Nandros has
said you contesting your reading of the
evidence. You are lying about the
evidence.
>> Quinn, I'm lying. Didn't
>> you can try and tell me to leave cuz you
just got totally blown the [__] out and
you were like, "Oh, well, I guess that
would be uh fine." And I had to come up
with a new narrative, but you are
totally lost on this, [__]
>> I'm lost on this. But weren't you the
first one to confidently assert a
totally false fact to check?
>> I made one mistake in the course of this
conversation. Yes. I made one mistake.
>> Mistake, right? You you How did you even
know what the doc's website was?
>> Because I went and checked the logs.
>> You went and checked the logs in the
thing and then you assumed. How did you
know that it was just for Twitter? When
you clicked the website, does it just
say Twitter?
>> Well, it's called LOL Archiver and it
says when when I click on it, it says
League of Legends history name history
checker.
You don't see the site on the left that
says Twitch tools, kick tools, LOL
archiver, database search, Twitter tool.
I assumed those were different tools. I
assume this was L Archiver was for
League of Legends and the other tools
were for other things.
>> Oh, was just off on the side. So, you
didn't really think about that.
>> I assumed. Yes, I assumed it was a
different search. I assumed it was a
>> different
I'm just curious then why
>> you are harping on this one mistake
because your broader narrative has
fallen apart. So make the actual
criticism or shut the [__] up.
>> Then why not just say now? No, I stand
by what I told Chloic. It was just a
lull account lookup. Before you thought
that they weren't involved the things on
the left. Now you're saying they were
involved the things on the left. Why do
you know which searches the person ran?
[bell]
>> Dude, what are you not understanding
here? I just said I looked at the
website. I thought it was a League of
Legends archiver. I thought the tools on
the side were different tools. That's
what I'm saying.
>> My question is uh my question is for
Shimu if he's still here. Um, so you had
to you had to send it off to another
person because you couldn't run it. Why?
>> You don't even know.
>> Because it cost money. It cost money,
Dan. It cost money. [laughter]
>> I'm asking.
>> No thing. I never sent anything.
>> Yeah, it wasn't Shimu. It was Nandros
who sent it off. What do you mean?
>> Read your own log, Dan. Read your own
[__] leak, Dan. Read your own leak.
>> Maybe if you unredact the people's
>> Yeah. How about you read that lean?
Familiarize yourself with your own
evidence and then come back. How about
that, Dan?
>> Understand what happened. Wait, could it
be because it costs money to do it that
someone might have to? Some features are
paid and you have to pay for certain
features like data breach and things
along those lines.
>> So, just acknowledge you just accused
Shimu of sending it off. It wasn't
Shimu, was it? That's in the logs.
>> No, sorry. Sorry. My fault. Uh, why did
you guys have to send it to someone? Why
didn't
>> Nandros sent it? Nandros,
>> why couldn't do it himself?
>> Because well, he said he didn't have
money. He didn't have the subscription.
>> I can explain this. I can explain this.
>> Okay. And and for the first thing where
he said this person No, I want to keep
explain before he did Archiver, he did
another one. He said there's this person
is not on Steam. It could be unique
enough to Sherlock. What is
>> Oh, Dan, can we just point out Sorry.
Yeah, Sherlock is one that doesn't
search breaches, by the way. Also, Dan,
can we just point out you actually lied
in this conversation earlier, didn't
you, Dan?
>> About what?
>> Well, you said that the Steam username
was different to the Twitter username,
but it wasn't, was it? They were just
searching the same username.
Uh,
>> is that the li that is the case? I've
got that in the logs. You lying [__]
>> Another lie.
>> You li another line. Wow. You lied to
me.
>> I can send it to you right now. Lying
[__] rats.
>> Dan,
>> never trusted.
>> So, they talk about this person's
username being Mister. Right, Dan?
Here's the substantiation for that.
Here's the relevant Twitter account. And
then we can show the rest of it. We show
the logs.
>> Here's here's the logs that you
redacted. So, you redacted the the
username that's redacted was in these
logs. The username in these logs, you
redacted it and said it was different to
the Twitter username. It's not, is it?
>> Sure.
>> Uh,
okay. Yeah, the Steam name here is the
same as that one.
>> Okay. So, you were wrong lying earlier,
weren't you, Dan?
>> Oh, well, I guess in your case, I could
say I'm mistaken. I'm sorry. In the docs
tool that they ran, uh, my bad. They
they you entered the same username twice
to get email. Like, if you want So, so
they were using So, they were using a
single username. I mean, one username
was post in there. They didn't post the
docs tool. They didn't run the docs tool
in there.
>> They did post they post they post twer
they did not post LOL archive. They
mentioned it.
>> Yes, they did. Oh. Oh, sorry. They
mentioned it. Okay.
>> I didn't If there's a meaningful
difference to you guys, that's fine.
I
>> I just want to be specific. If we're
being specific, I want to be very
specific with your allegations. So on
his specific what are you accusing Shimu
of what are you accusing Shimu of answer
my question what are you accusing Shimu
of answer my question now
>> I'm trying to find the actual real life
identity of an anonymous Twitter account
and then being and then being able
trying to find or trying to dox trying
to find or trying to dox
>> oh sorry trying to dox the identity off
of a user okay so where's so you think
Shimu is trying to publish it that's
what you think for the purpose of
harassment
Well, I mean, uh, could be. I have no
[__] idea. He said he hated the
person, right?
>> Nice one, you [__] [__] You have
no idea. Nice one, you [__] [__]
>> You little [__] man.
>> Okay. I Is this like a win for you guys
right here? Like, you're putting in
people's username.
>> Dan, let me ask you this. Teto. Is Teto
incredibly accused of being a rapist
with a protective order?
>> Oh. Um, I think so, but I'm not.
>> Okay. So, would it be logical to make
sure Teone isn't violating his order and
harassing his victim?
>> Oh, for you? No. You're not the [__]
police. You don't have a PI license.
You're not allowed to be going out and
[__] like looking up people's [__] in
data breach anymore. The answer is no.
Not for you. You're not their [__]
white knight [__]
>> I shouldn't I shouldn't say anything
about I should just like Okay. Yeah.
>> Are you their [__] protector? No.
You're not the [__] you don't have a
license to do this. It's against the law
for you to do it.
>> If it's it's against the law. Are you
kidding me?
>> Yes. Yes. To look up data breaches. Yes,
it is. Yes, it is.
>> You're leaking court documents and
harassing and that's bad. That's bad.
And the police should [__] Yeah. Wait,
wait. Just to be clear, nobody nobody in
that server as far as you can show from
the evidence you've shown so far. I
haven't seen it was has actually looked
anything up on a data breach site from
what from what I've seen.
>> Oh. Oh, okay. That's cope because I
Well, first off, I love this idea that
uh this type of thing now is not doxing
because this is great because you guys
are going to have a There is going to be
so much compilation that I will put
together of the both of you guys going
[__] nuts over people looking up
people's information.
>> I've never never I've always been
specific about my definition of do
publishing for the purpose of
harassment. That is what I say every
time. I'm specific.
>> If you don't publish it, it's fine.
>> You're correct. Correct. You can look
into whatever you want on your own time.
On your own time privately, you can look
up what you like.
If you harass me on Twitter and I'm
like, "This guy, I think he's [__]
some other dude's alt and I look you up.
Uh, I'm okay.
I'm [__] sexually assaulted.
>> You can look it up as long as you don't
publish stuff, Dan. You can look up what
you want."
>> The protective order doesn't apply to
random people on the internet. I don't
know why you keep bringing up the
protective order.
>> No, harassment and stalking was like
part of the thing.
>> Sorry
people on the internet.
>> It's not a random person. The idea was
that it was someone that might be
connected to TechOne because they had
very few followers and they were all
just like Tee Asmin Godova and all these
people.
>> The only way to know that would be to
dox the account.
>> No, you wouldn't be doxing if you don't
publish it, would you?
>> But you were planning on sending the
information to somebody involved in a
>> would be planning send it to the
relevant party to be used in a legal
case, not published for the purpose of
harassment. You lying rat.
>> You have no idea. Don't call me a lying
rat. You lied about every single part of
this. You
>> Where's the lie? Where's the lie? I
admitted to one mistake. I've not lied
about a single part of this.
>> It wasn't a mistake, though. It was a It
was a boldfaced lie.
>> It was not a bold-faced lie, you [__]
disgusting.
>> It was a mistake. How is it a
>> Why would I Why would I bother lying
about that? We disproved in a moment on
a public website. You [__] idiot. I'm
sending you all the evidence.
>> You're not lying about it. You lied
about it because you knew that I said
that I didn't know.
>> [__] You're a [__] idiot. You're so
washed, bro. I can't believe I actually
thought you were good at this [__] back
in the day. I give you
It's so [__] sad how far you [__]
harder than just like circle jerking
with your friends. Remember, remember
all the [__] you said about internet
freedom and the definition of doxing
when you were getting slandered by
catbarge and careful. Remember that [__]
you [__] lying rodent?
>> What is that?
>> Remember when you getting slandered by
[__] cat ten and barge the [__]
dog [__] journalist carefuls. All these
[__] people coming after you saying
all this [__] about the doxing you do
all this [__] You had perfectly clean
definitions of doxing back then. You
were perfectly pro internet freedom
posting on kiwi farms and all this stuff
back then. And now all of a sudden your
stands are [__] swapped. What are you
even talking about? Hold on. Was was my
complaint back then that I was being
doxed or I don't even know what you're
referring to.
>> No, I didn't say you were complaining
about being doxed. But if you want to
keep playing like a [__] [__] go
for it, man.
>> I'm just asking you to clarify because
you're emotionally.
>> They were accusing They were accusing
you of doxing and all this [__] for
posting Careful's Kiwi Farms thread. You
were being accused of coordinating
swatting and all this sort of [__]
against Carefuls. You took issue with
that back in the day. Now you use that
same tactic against other people.
>> Yeah. I think I think I think you're
confusing this with the accusations that
you guys like to make against me that
you took from when I just swine. When
have I used swine? When have I ever
swine that I
>> Oh, well, let me just ask you because
maybe I'm wrong. Have you ever said that
I doxed Anavoir because I posted her
Kiwi Farms thread or directed people to
it?
>> Um, yeah. Yeah. You you
>> Oh, then then there you go. Do you see
how did you just ask me a question? You
see how hard this is when you're not
post
>> I don't post Kiwi Farms links because
they because they all have names in the
URL. They have names in the URL, [__]
>> They have full names in the URL, you
[__] idiot.
>> They have full names in the URL. They
have full names in the URL, you low
life. Go look after your son. Get off
the internet. It's embarrassing.
>> I am smacking you.
>> Do Kiwi Farms have the names in the
titles? Yes or no? Yes or no? Destiny,
answer my question. Answer my question,
Destiny. Do Kiwi Farms threads have the
name in the title? Yes or no?
>> I'm not sure which Kiwi Farm.
>> Yes, Anavois does, doesn't it?
>> I don't know. I haven't thread because
in your [__] chat log.
>> 20 years. 20 years. Yeah. You had it on
stream two days ago. Bro,
>> I I post Do I post the link to her
thread in my in the chat thing?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And you know that?
>> Okay. Then why is it the one I just
asked you, have you ever accused me of
doxing? Why did you say no? I never said
I didn't accuse you of docking. I've
accused doxing. You have doxed. I said
you haven't accused you of swatting.
>> When were we talking about swatting in
here?
>> That's what you got accused of
coordinating against Cat 10. Where this
came from, you [__] [__]
>> Wait a minute. You're lost. Wait a
minute. You're lost.
>> I'm per being perfectly clear with you,
you [__] idiot.
>> If you would have pulled up a real life
name for that Twitter account, how would
you have known if it was Tech Tones Mod
or not?
>> Huh? What' you say? If you would have
pulled up a real life name on the
Twitter account, how would you have
known if that was a mod of Techone or
not?
>> I mean, I wasn't pulling up anything,
but I would the only thing I I was just
interested in seeing if it was mods
because
>> he would cross reference using that
cross reference the usernames from the
chat or the Discord. But do you agree
that it would be bad if Teone was
directing his mods to harass somebody
that he has a protection order against?
>> Do you think that would be bad?
>> If you pulled up a real life username
>> Okay, so you're not going to answer
cross reference. No, no. If you're going
to cross reference that with what? How
what would you cross reference it with?
>> Dude, we everyone's already said this.
The Discord. So, they have usernames in
a Discord and probably the chat.
>> Sure.
>> No, they don't use real life names. But
again, you're harping on a point where
it's like nobody is publishing
information, so it's not doxing. But you
keep going back to this because you're
kind of scrambling to find a way to make
this smear work.
>> If it's not doxing, this is why I know
you don't believe that because if it
wasn't doxing, you'd have no problem
just answering my questions. Honestly,
you would say, "Yeah, we would do that."
Yeah, of course.
>> Dude, you you've asked these same
questions like over and over again
to try to get this napping like you're
doing right now.
>> Literally, you literally asked this
earlier before you and went out of
>> Okay, then remind me what did you say?
How would you be able to cross reference
a real life name? Let's say all you
could find on the Twitter is a real life
name. How would you be able to cross
reference that with Techton's Twitter
mods or Techton's mods period on Twitch
or YouTube or whatever else?
>> But see, now you're trying to walk it
down where it's like if you found that
you'd have to find the name or
something. But none of that happened.
You're like coming up with hypotheticals
to try to manipulate your [__]
audience to think like, "Oh, these
people were doxing." But nobody was
doxing. It was a smear. And with that,
>> if I as
Okay, that's good. That's good. Okay.
>> I have to stop. I did have to stop at
two. Uh,
>> you're good.
>> But see,
>> anyways.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Great smear, guys. Awesome. I think you
guys got blown the [__] out. Pretty
embarrassing.
>> True.
>> I mean, yeah, this
>> Yeah, you do not deserve any more oxygen
for this [__] So, [__] you. You [__]
low life pervert. You belong in prison.
Truly.
>> Thank you for coming in, Queman. It's
funny cuz I think you came in as the
champion and you said like even more
[__] [__]
>> You got completely [__] raped, dude.
The clips going to be great. Trust me,
we're going to boost those like crazy.
Seriously, man. You're going to [__]
love it.
>> Why would you reveal?
>> Can I give you I'll give you some free
advice. Listen, okay, you guys should do
mock debates or something cuz like this
circle jerk [__] that you guys do, why
would you agree to debate?
>> You got totally raped. You posted Kiwi
Farms thread with the full name in the
link in your chat. That's doxing. You
got raped, you [__] idiot. Worst
you've been since you were 10 years old.
[__] yourself. You disgusting low life.
>> Okay. Okay.
I left. I left. I told him there's no
more oxygen for that. [__] that. So
guys, just to explain to you what was
going on there. Just to explain to you
what was going on there. Okay. So
basically Dan and Lonerbox got their
hands on like some [__] like
spin-off server. It's like one of 500
Splinter servers of different spices and
all this [__] And they're using these
logs
to say that Nandros and Shimu were
doxing. Now, what actually happens in
these logs?
>> Thank you guys. Thank you. Huge
appreciated. What actually happens in
these logs is Nandros and Shimu are
discussing a Twitter account that is
harassing Pinky Chu
>> Tech's victim with AI edits and slander
and all this [__] on Twitter. They see
an account doing that with almost no
followers and that's all they do and
they just follow TeeOne, Novaru, and
Asminold. Three people are all friends.
They go into Discord and they say,
"Let's research this and see if this is
someone directly connected to Tee
because that would be likely, if
coordinated, a breach of their
protective order. So, we will pass that
information to Pinky Chu for her case."
And they're saying that's doxing.
Do you know what's interesting is what a
lying wretch you are. It's disgusting.
You have smeared Shimu and Kandros as
some sort of doxers and they're not. You
got nothing.
>> You're coping and you're going to get
blown the [__] out with all the
compilation of you calling this doxing
in the past. And for everyone else who
wants to do the sweeping, not calling
this doxing, I hate to say it. I've
literally so specific with my definition
of doxing every time I've ever said it.
These people are human. Dan is human.
Destiny is human. Seriously, they do not
deserve even a [__] voice online.
>> If you're going to be much of a
dishonest [__] rat as this could have
done better, but that was content, dude.
That was
>> Sorry, guys. I'm catching up on
something. Obviously, I you know,
[laughter]
>> I was watching the stream and I realized
I was late for my stream and then Chud's
adding me while I'm on the waiting
screen. So, I'm like so behind on
everything. I've got no idea what's
going on. I'm going [music] to need like
a minute.
Don't wait till 2030 when everyone post
talk hawk rationalizes and says that I
actually should qu look really bad in
this conversation.
>> Stamps to money.
>> I think he deleted this cuz he said post
talk rationalize. It's post hawk.
[music]
>> Oh my god. Okay.
[bell]
It's not doxing. We're just gathering
private information, unmasking anonymous
accounts to pass their information
someone else. Correct. That's not
doxing. Correct. If you pass it to
someone else for a legitimate purpose,
that's not doxing. If you publicize it
for the purpose of harassment, that's
doxing.
What do people not understand here? What
do people not understand here? The line
is very clear. The issues with doxing
are very clear. Doxing is not when
someone may actually have legitimate
legal action to be taken against them
and you pass information to the relevant
party.
>> I can hear your addressing here.
>> It's truly it's so [__] disgusting.
>> Take a break, man. You've earned it
>> again. It's not even they are not even
like it's what you know I don't want to
be you know I don't want to f so it's
one thing if it was against like me or J
sulk you know it's one thing against
your [__] dragon Shimu and the
canra's name through the mud over
nothing simply because you think they're
associated with us. [__] you.